salud en directo América de Francia 24
más Romero sala ya está con nosotros en
el estudio Mara bienvenida digamos a
hablar de la Organización Mundial de la
Salud que decidió mantener el brote de
la viruela del mono como una emergencia
internacional Sí para los que estábamos
esperando que quizás todavía no podemos
dar esas buenas noticias del comité de
hecho se reunió ayer es de ayer en
noticias recordamos además que fue en
julio que se declaró el brote de viruela
del mono como una emergencia
internacional y que se reúnen lo revaló
en cada tres meses la siguiente reunión
entonces va a ser en enero de la que
estaremos pendientes Pero bueno veamos
el informe las razones que daba la OMS
para mantener este nivel de alerta
el comité mantuvo el consenso que el
evento sigue cumpliendo Los criterios
para una emergencia de salud pública de
preocupación internacional las
principales razones son la transmisión
continuada en algunas regiones la
desigualdad en la respuesta y la
preparación entre países de la OMS un
potencial de impacto en la salud mayor
en poblaciones vulnerables el riesgo
continuado de estigma y discriminación
el surestro en países con sistema de
salud más débiles y la falta de acceso
equitativo en acceso a diagnósticos
antivirales y vacunas a pesar de todos
estos motivos que expone la OMS también
reconocen que han habido muchos
progresos como recordábamos
recientemente en Europa en Estados
Unidos por ejemplo que se deben pues al
cambio de comportamiento de los
principales grupos de riesgo también a
la administración Aunque algo tropezada
de las vacunas de hecho hasta dos
personas del comité decidieron que no
era ya una emergencia internacional pero
que preferían todavía mantener
públicamente este nivel para que no se
retrocediera con los pasos que se habían
dado hasta ahora actualmente este brote
tenemos ya casi 48.000 de casos y 36
muertes en los países que no son
endémicos 109 países no endémicos de la
viruela del mono no la OMS además
mantuvo de nuevo la recomendaciones de
aumentar la vigilancia de reducir estas
desigualdades de las que hablaba y
también recordó que el estigma alrededor
de las comunidades más vulnerables
actualmente a este brote fuera de los
países endémicos como son los hombres
gay o los hombres bisexuales están
sufriendo un estigma en muchos países
Igualmente que está haciendo que todo
este tratamiento o el acceso a las
vacunas se retrase por lo tanto Pues
alertó a que los países los gobiernos
intenten reducir estos estigmas que
pesan sobre esta comunidad y sobre estas
personas así es mar y qué regiones del
mundo son las que tienen más riesgo en
este brote pues globalmente se considera
que el riesgo ahora mismo es moderado
sin embargo eso es distinto según las
regiones vamos a ver cómo lo divide la
Organización Mundial de la Salud de
hecho el continente americano en el que
estamos en el que se considera que está
en el riesgo más alto actualmente
mientras que Europa está transitando un
riesgo alto a un riesgo moderado al
resto de regiones están en un riesgo
moderado Como por ejemplo África medio
oriente Asia también parte de Asia y el
resto de lo que la bmc se llama Pacífico
occidental están en un riesgo bajo por
qué todas estas denominaciones Por
ejemplo en América a pesar de que
Estados Unidos está pues disminuyendo
sus casos de contagio tenemos otros
países como por ejemplo México o
Colombia mismo también donde esas
tendencias a la baja no están siendo tan
claras Y de hecho se sigue propagando el
brote y en África una de las cosas que
tienen miedo y de hecho una de las cosas
que también hace que se mantenga este
estatus de emergencia actualmente es el
subregistro que puede haber actualmente
solo en este año 2022 en los países
donde sí es endémico en el continente
africano han habido 173 muertes una
cifra mucho más alta que las que se ha
registrado en todo el mundo en el brote
entonces por eso bueno se está
decidiendo mantener este nivel de alerta
y seguir dándoles estos niveles entre
moderados y altos en varias de las
regiones del mundo mar y en el
continente africano porque en uganda
avanza el brote de ébola Lamentablemente
sí lamentablemente no no da tregua no a
pesar de que las autoridades siguen
afirmando de que está bajo control de
que todavía no hay que hacer sonar todas
las alarmas posibles usar todos los
recursos contra esta enfermedad en eso
no significa que no estén aumentando los
casos vamos a revisar las cifras del
último de la última publicación del
Ministerio de la salud de uganda estamos
hablando de 130 casos confirmados 43
muertes confirmadas de las cuales al
menos seis se han dado en trabajadores
de la salud que estaban respondiendo a
la emergencia además la tasa de rastreo
está alrededor del 88%, y eso no es tan
buena noticia debería estar al menos por
encima del 90 para asegurarnos de que
sabemos el alcance Real del brote y
cuáles están siendo las vías de
transmisión sobre todo teniendo en
cuenta que por ejemplo el brote ha
llegado a campala la capital de uganda
donde Pues en lugares como poblados como
las ciudades se puede perder un poco el
rastreo del caso del brote perdón este
brote Además ya está entre los 10
mayores del mundo es estar ahora mismo
número de casos en el octavo caso por
ejemplo en el octavo en la posición y
uganda por ejemplo en el año 2000 tuvo
425 casos es más del triple del actual
es decir estamos lejos de las
situaciones más graves que atravesado el
país pero no tanto y esperemos que que
no llegue ahí así es Y finalizamos este
bloque de salud del día de hoy con una
buena noticia mar una nueva vacuna de
pfizer enfocada en los recién nacidos sí
es una vacuna contra el rcv son las
siglas en inglés del virus respiratorio
siniestral no que provoca resfriados
comunes normalmente entre la población
adulta sin embargo en este caso está
enfocado a los bebés que pueden
desarrollar casos graves de enfermedad
los resultados publicados por la empresa
es que protegen contra la enfermedad
grave provocada por este virus en un
81,8% Durante los tres primeros meses de
vida y durante el primer medio año de
vida los primeros seis meses se baja un
poquito
69,4% Igualmente una protección alta
para tener Pues en consideración como
siempre las cifras las tomamos con
cautela recordamos que son piedras
publicadas solo por la farmacéutica no
sean revisado no se han publicado en una
revista científica Entonces tenemos que
tener en cuenta esto pero bueno no deja
de ser una buena señal sobre todo porque
se fue en un estudio de fase 3 en un
estudio bastante amplio una cosa curiosa
es que esta vacuna además se aplica en
las personas gestantes en la segundo
término del embarazo a partir de los
seis meses en la última mitad del
embarazo básicamente y a pesar Como
decíamos de que este virus en adultos
suele provocar resfriados comunes en
personas mayores o en bebés puede
desarrollar por ejemplo casos de
pulmonía o de enfermedades graves solo
en Estados Unidos por ejemplo 58.000
niños menores de 5 años se hospitalizan
cada año debido a la afección de este
virus así que bueno Esto podría cambiar
un poco este panorama Así es cambiar
para positivo mar como siempre
Muchísimas gracias mañana más salud
mañana